like i said the finale is coming and
with that fast and the furious finale
vin diesel is ready to let bygones be
bygones with former co-star dwayne the
rock johnson here's the thing about it
right so we're all adults on sunday the
actor extended an olive branch to the
former wwe star on instagram publicly
asking dwayne to return to the fast
franchise after their long-standing beef
then posted a photo of their characters
dominic toretto and luke hobbs and
captioned it in part quote my little
brother dwayne the time has come the
world awaits the finale of fast 10. as
you know my children refer to you as
uncle dwayne in my house there is not a
holiday that goes by that they and you
don't send well wishes but the time has
come legacy awaits i told you years ago
that i was going to fulfill my promise
to pablo pablo is vin's nickname for
their co-star paul walker who died in a
car crash in 2013.
to some people that's more important in
vince post he insists that dwayne must
show up and asks him to not leave the
franchise idol quote hobbs can't be
played by no other i hope that you rise
to the occasion and fulfill your destiny
it ain't too late to stop this
the last time diesel and johnson
appeared on screen together in a fast
and furious movie was in 2017's the fate
of the furious the actors reportedly had
a falling out on the set which became
public in 2016 when johnson called a few
of his male f8 co-stars candy asses and
unprofessional on social media fans were
quick to speculate that dwayne was
referring to vin a topic he addressed
while speaking with e.t in
2017. oftentimes
just like in life you have different
philosophies and people have different
philosophies different fundamental
philosophies on how you do things
and again the most important thing is
just the movies at the time a source
told et that the two actors definitely
clashed on set due to vin's failure to
be on time which was the complete
opposite of dwayne but in a vanity fair
profile published last month dwayne
admitted that he regrets airing their
dirty laundry he says publicly
discussing their drama quote wasn't my
best day the jumaji star reveals he met
with vin to squash things after the post
went viral but it wasn't a peaceful
meeting adding that it became clear to
him that they are on two separate ends
of the spectrum and he decided to leave
it there nine aligns starts to align
everything perfectly
for the
greatest finale in cinematic history
following this summer's release of f9
the fast and furious franchise will
conclude with its final two films f10
and f11. we'll have to stay tuned to see
if dwayne takes vin up on his offer and
makes an appearance but in the meantime
e.t recently spoke with a former pro
wrestler about a joke centered around
vin that's in his latest movie red
notice also starring ryan reynolds and
gal gadot
you know ryan loves to improv and i love
that i've known ron ryan for a long time
and
20 years man we go way back i've known
ryan longer than anyone in hollywood and
so that's how close we are and uh the
the the vin joke
uh audiences love it uh very very funny
but uh that was ryan he came up with
that
he came up with a few of them
and i thought that was the one that
could be funny and you know look in a
movie like this you got to have a sense
of humor